SCP-049 was many things: a doctor, an enemy
of The Pestilence, a seemingly immortal masked
anomaly contained by the SCP Foundation, but
above all else, he was a scholar, a man in
constant pursuit of knowledge.
Whether he was conducting whatever experiments
he could get away with in containment, reading
the various medical texts he was allowed upon
request, or asking questions of his fellow
anomalies as they passed by his cell, he was
always looking for new information and additional
subjects of study.
Sometimes they pertained to the Pestilence,
but other times they were simply things that
he engaged with for the pure joy of discovery
and understanding.
After a bout of particularly impressive good
behavior, namely a willingness to cooperate
with questions from researchers and a record-breaking
streak of days without any reanimation of
deceased tissue, the Plague Doctor was given
the exciting opportunity to peruse a selection
of official SCP files.
Any potentially compromising information was
heavily redacted, of course, but the Doctor
was nevertheless thrilled at the chance.
He greedily devoured file after file while
sipping a cup of hot tea, poring over reports
of invisible women and supernatural vending
machines.
Finally, he came to the file for SCP-2935.
As the Doctor read about the space-time anomaly
in a cave in Indiana, holding the gateway
to another reality where all life mysteriously
ended, his mind began to race with possibilities.
What could have wiped out everything so efficiently,
in such a perfect, horrible swoop, on the
date of April 20, 2016?
He could think of only one explanation, and
he began to obsess.
After days of rereading the file again and
again, the Plague Doctor could take no more.
He requested an audience with a Senior Researcher,
and was granted a meeting with Sr. Researcher
Sun.
"What did you want to ask me about?"
Dr. Sun inquired.
"Please, Doctor...You must understand, there
is so little I can do to continue my work
in my current state.
Meanwhile, the Pestilence rages on outside
of these walls, at times even within them,
and I can do nothing.
But this!"
He held up the file for SCP-2935.
"This may hold the key to all that I seek.
I only ask that you permit me to venture inside
on a research expedition of my own."
"You want to go...into SCP-2935?"
Dr. Sun had prepared herself for a lot of
possible requests, but this was not one of
them.
"Yes, Doctor, I do."
"And...you understand what that would mean?"
Dr. Sun studied the Plague Doctor's face,
but the mask revealed no expression but stony
determination.
"You wouldn't be able to come back, you would
have to stay there, indefinitely."
"I understand.
That is a sacrifice I am fully prepared to
make.
Out of one prison and into another, yes?
But there, I will have so much to study.
So much to learn.
Perhaps, I will at last find the answers I
seek."
Dr. Sun nodded.
"Let me speak to the higher-ups about this.
I'll see what they have to say."
The Plague Doctor waited patiently in his
cell, thinking of nothing but the verdict
that awaited him, until finally Dr. Sun returned.
"Yes, Doctor?
What is it?"
"Your request has been approved."
Dr. Sun sounded almost surprised.
"We'll get you transported to Indiana tomorrow."
"Then I suppose I must bid you adieu, Doctor."
The Plague Doctor nodded solemnly.
"Goodbye...Doctor."
Dr. Sun gave him a nod in return, then turned
and left SCP-049's cell for the last time.
The next day, SCP-049 was moved to a secure
transport vehicle, and driven to a nondescript
cemetery near Joppa, Indiana.
There, operatives led him to the cave entrance
below, where it was sealed with concrete.
They brought with them tools to dismantle
the concrete seal, and additional concrete
to close the entrance back up once SCP-049
was inside.
There would truly be no going back for the
Plague Doctor once he embarked on this last
great experiment.
Once the way was cleared out, SCP-049 turned
to face his escorts.
"Gentlemen, I thank you for your service.
I only hope that I may honor it by at last
defeating the Pestilence that threatens this
world."
Unsure of what to say in response, the officers
could only give him a silent salute.
In the moment before he stepped over the threshold,
the Plague Doctor recalled a snippet of Shakespeare
he had once heard at the theatre, many many
years ago.
He repeated it now: "Once more unto the breach,
dear friends, once more."
And he walked into the unknown.
This strange new world was, at first, indistinguishable
from the old one that the Doctor had left
behind.
It was just as the file had said, everything
was identical, just entirely absent of life.
That was the first detail the Plague Doctor
noticed, the dry vegetation poking up from
the earth.
Brown leaves curling from petrified tree branches,
pale grass parting the cracked dirt.
The second detail to catch his attention was
the silence, deafening silence.
Back at the Foundation Site, there was always
noise: the clatter of footsteps down the hall,
pens scratching on clipboards, alarms blaring,
strange creatures wailing in the distance,
D-Class screaming.
Here, there was nothing, only the hollow whistle
of the wind.
In this moment, as he stood at the top of
a hill staring out at a vast landscape of
emptiness, the Plague Doctor felt doubt creeping
in.
Had he made a mistake, coming to this place?
He had hoped to find knowledge here, had hoped
to unlock the secrets of the Pestilence, but
perhaps he had just consigned himself to a
lonely, eternal grave.
But no!
He shook away the feeling.
There was no sense in becoming discouraged
so soon, when there was so much still to discover.
He would explore the landscape and see what
surprises awaited.
There would be time to despair later.
And so, the Plague Doctor walked.
He walked past fields of cattle lying on their
sides, so undisturbed they almost appeared
to be sleeping if it weren't for their complete
and utter stillness.
The lack of decomposition gave him pause,
as he realized that microbial life must have
been eliminated by this world's Great Dying
as well.
He stepped around broken birds where they
had fallen clear out of the sky and landed
on the ground, and looked pitifully at the
cars parked on the side of the road with long-dead
drivers still inside.
The world, just as it was at the moment of
collective death.
It was as fascinating as it was tragic.
After a long walk through the infinite graveyard,
the Doctor saw a building up ahead that piqued
his interest: a hospital left abandoned, windows
caked with dust.
He couldn't be sure what he hoped to find
inside, but a building filled with medical
equipment, and possibly beds filled with deceased
patients to examine, would be an excellent
place to start.
SCP-049 wandered the halls of the hospital,
gathering supplies as he went and placing
them into his trusty black bag.
He was admiring an IV stand when he heard
something curious: a metallic clank, coming
from down the hall.
It was notable, not only because the building
appeared so empty, but because it was the
first sound he had heard since stepping into
the cave and leaving his world behind.
Could it be?
Could something else be alive in this place
after all?
He followed the sound eagerly to its source,
an operating room at the end of the hallway.
He opened the door, and came face to face
with the last thing he ever expected to see:
himself.
This figure was slightly different, wearing
a deep red mask instead of the Doctor's signature
white.
But everything else was the same, from the
gloved hands, to the robes, to the beak, to
the bag of implements and samples at his feet.
The red-masked doctor regarded him with a
pleasant curiosity as they locked eyes.
"Hello, Doctor."
"Hello.
I must ask, my dear fellow...are you me?"
"I do believe I must be."
The red-masked doctor said simply.
"I have never seen anyone else like you before.
Like us.
Where did you come from?"
"From a world much like this one."
The Doctor explained.
He went on to tell his double the entire story,
from his capture by the Foundation, to his
discovery of the SCP-2935 file, every step
of the journey that brought him to this very
place.
"I had hoped to conduct research and discover
enough to fill my solitude, but with you here..."
His imagination brimmed with possibilities.
"You could tell me, if you will, what happened
to reduce the world to this state?"
"The necessary cost of scientific advancement
is what happened."
The red-masked doctor responded.
"Collateral damage, as is to be expected in
any great endeavor."
"What do you mean?"
The Doctor frowned.
"The Pestilence did this, surely?"
"In a sense."
The red-masked doctor's eyes glittered behind
his mask.
"As my work progressed, this result became...unavoidable,
you see.
It was the only way to cure them.
One must purge the poison entirely, if no
other solution can be found."
"Do you mean to tell me..."
The Plague Doctor struggled to find the words.
"That you did this?"
"Do not look so shocked, new friend."
The red-masked doctor scoffed.
"If we are alike, then you certainly must
have sacrificed a great deal to the pursuit
of a cure.
It is for the greater good, yes?"
"Yes, I suppose I have...but not like this.
Never like this."
He shook his head.
"What are we, as doctors, with no more patients
to treat?"
"Free."
The red-masked doctor smiled.
"No, no, no."
The Doctor could not believe what he was hearing.
"What of your world?"
His twin demanded.
"What became of the patients there?"
"I left them behind, in search of my cure
here."
The Doctor retorted.
The red masked figure paused thoughtfully.
"They are all...still there?
On the other side of this SCP-2935?
Where did you say the entrance was, my friend?"
"I neglected to mention it.
And I never will.
You will not go back through that gateway!"
The Doctor backed away from the red-masked
man in horror.
This figure looked like him, but he was villainous,
cold, and cruel.
"No matter.
I will go to Site 19 and find the file myself.
After all, I have all the time in the world."
The red masked doctor swept out of the room,
leaving SCP-049 stunned.
If the other Doctor discovered the location
of that gateway, if he returned to the other
world...the same terrible fate would befall
every living thing there.
It was his duty as a Doctor to ensure that
did not happen.
As fast as his legs could carry him, the Doctor
raced to Site-19.
He only hoped he would not be too late.
At the abandoned Foundation Site, the Plague
Doctor tore through the halls searching for
a hint of movement, for a glint of red that
might lead him to his wicked other.
If he could not find him...there was another
way.
He dimly recalled overhearing the location
of an emergency switch, only to be flipped
in the most dire of circumstances when all
else was lost.
Now was the time for such a switch, the Plague
Doctor knew.
Just as he had the switch in his sights, the
Plague Doctor heard a voice behind him.
"You will not stop me.
Why not join me?
We could be colleagues, battling the Pestilence
together."
The red masked doctor held out a hand in invitation.
"You are as foul a plague as the Pestilence
itself."
The Plague Doctor hissed.
"Then I will leave you here alone."
The red masked doctor spat.
"Neither you nor I will ever leave this place.
I will make sure of it."
The Plague Doctor reached for the switch as
the realization dawned on the other doctor's
face.
The red-masked Doctor lunged desperately at
his counterpart, but it was too late: the
Plague Doctor flipped the switch, and the
countdown began.
The on-site nuclear warhead was preparing
to detonate.
"You fool!"
The red masked doctor hissed.
"This will kill us both!"
"It may, but on the other side of that great
divide, they shall live."
The Plague Doctor replied.
"The Pestilence will take them all!"
The Plague Doctor shook his head.
"Perhaps you are right.
But I believe they will find a way to fight.
You and I will not get the chance to see who
is correct, I fear.
But I have made my peace with that."
"You have ruined everything!"
The red-masked doctor insisted, but the Plague
Doctor did not hear.
He was already closing his eyes, listening
to the countdown.
"Once more..."
He murmured to himself.
"Unto the breach..."
The tinny voice over the speakers counted
down: "3...2...1..."
Now go check out “SCP-049 Cures SCP-096
of the Pestilence?!”
and “SCP-049 - What Actually is the Pestilence?
The Plague Doctor Questions and Theories”
for more Plague Doctor!